[Music]
romantics will tell you that the heart
of buenos aires beats to the rhythm of
the tango
[Music]
the tango world cup is held every year
in the city where it was born at the end
of the 19th century
last year it was all virtual however
tango is all about cheap to cheat
closeness and it does not sit well with
social distancing so this year it was
back both in person and on screen
the tango is is a mirror of what is
going on in our society in general so i
truly believe that
[Music]
of course it impacts on us
tango salons have been closed for a year
and a half while argentina is now
emerging from the pandemic measures to
deal with it is still in place so while
the dancers could get close they and the
spectators were moved to a safer venue
tangle has always survived and thrived
it has adapted to changing times and
circumstances
little more so than now this version
being held in the open air in the heart
of buenos aires with all the spectators
wearing masks it has brought the dance
and music back to the streets where it
began
closer to the people
tango is constantly being
composed again and again we have new
composers new dancers new stories to be
told
or old stories told in a new way the
tango world cup paid homage to the
winner of the 1986 football world cup
diego maradona who died last november
tango is steeped in nostalgia and one of
its most acclaimed dancers 87 year old
maria nieves reminded the audience that
it never forgets its roots
that's reflected in the technique of
traditional salon tango one this year by
agustin anies and barbara ferreira
but it must always say the winners of
the choreographed stage tango category
look to the future
[Music]
people of our age need to be
contemporary and reflect what's
happening today
tango has to keep evolving just like
everything else
the pandemic may have muffled the music
but the two by four beat of the tango
goes on bringing in the heart of buenos
aires alive again
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires
[Music]